allez c'est parti dingle le champion de
la nascar au débat champion de la trempe
de l'adar cas allez on va démarrer avec
big lots explose si vous nous rejoignez
pas ce que je disais qu elle a rtl sur
la tête de ma mère elle tellement jeune
par rapport aux doutes cbi cloud quand
il arrive à un truc de ouf quoi alors
oui c'est pas reçu une des plus vieilles
non c'est pas tout cas vous êtes
magnifique est bon pour le col roulé son
pull alami que le colon le truc que le
colloque hall c'est un ami l'aurait à
l'ap a mis le reste allait aussi oui
alors vous savez quel point j'aime pas
avoir de l'eau sur la tête
eh ben c'est pas le cas des deux hommes
qu'on va voir dans cette vidéo parce que
eux ils n'ont pas eu la patience
d'attendre la fin du confinement pour
prendre un bain mais comme sites
interdits ils ont truander je vous
laisse regarder aller on est sur vidéo
gag 19,62 vous nous rejoignez ce bonbon
c'est parti et le lancement frère
là j'ai fait un bond sans déconner l'aja
vdab et 204 regarder quoi ces conneries
qui fit bon rap est un fait des mecs qui
fibre
mais fatigué
diffus
[Musique]
c'est un bon joueur nick et ça me fait
rêver qu'un jour c'est marie bejamin
bonne une bonne compétition rose tyrien
par les biens forme j'avais un bonnet de
combiner ces additions n'a pas tous ses
appareils
eva bonnier de compétition des couleurs
et il ya un bateau qui a cru que j'étais
une bouée une bouée dans la partie
bouffer c'est ça le gars des vues
sa femme ne dit jamais dit que c'était
quelqu'un pour kaka elle bouge encore je
ne vois pas comment c'est génial
follement effet avec nous c'est que du
qui fasse foi est celle ci en plus
qu'une anecdote que nous avait on n'a
pas vu comme quoi franchement la forêt
nous fait du bien elle tue à buner en
forêt ça la roue du gant c'est un truc
de zana allée chez mais kelly pavlik
vidéo qui oui alors vous savez à quel
point tous je passe mes nuits sur les
réseaux sociaux
et j'ai trouvé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
souper champêtre par l'amicale jeanne
d'arc à genoux a dit m cramé d'une
bewkes du médical et besson vincent
sociale et vous c'est quoi ça
alors attendez vous montrer les
moquettes après parce que alors aimer
loi passée que chez sa mère le gazon
alors ses téléspectateurs qui vont voter
dans un instant regardez vous votez les
cherry pour 3 moquette qu'on doit poser
sur le plateau merci et j'éteins d'amour
tu es une bombe le vert le bleu le blanc
vous décidez vert bleu blanc vous bottez
d'accord vous vous mettez quoi beinheim
blanc mamane toikeusse te plait merci
raymond le petit bleu de damas à
pourquoi pas le label bleu bleu aussi
couleurs de la paix cela bleus j'aurais
bien vu du rouge c'est trop tard ben moi
aussi moi moi moi j'aime bien le bleu
aussi mais il paraît il paraît les
spécialistes et les disent que c'est
mieux blanc moi je préfère le bleu
puisque je suis apparemment un
spécialiste
gratuit voilà alors qu'elle veut voir la
vidéo de d'isabelle morini-bosc sais pas
si vous avez gagné avec votre vidéo
c'est vous qui votez pour la meilleure
vidéo bien sûr chez vous kelly vdev 10
mai sur une petite fille bonsoir et qui
voit la vie en rose un petit peu comme
moi donc vous savez que je passe mes
nuits sur les réseaux donc j'ai craqué
sur elle et je vous l'annoncé vocale à
la wii
là on est karine ferri tf1 2011 l'akwaba
quoi c'est bien karine ferri ou et on
n'est pas comme ça on est pas en 2020
demande habitués à ce que la vie est
belle mais selon son voeu voit plus la
vis comme tout coup c'est un peu triste
et ils vont profiter de la vie
la vie c'est joli c'est bon on peut
voyager je t'ai rigoler sur la terre
toutes les jolies laisser souhaité avoir
quelques pas sur la terre ce après on
les voit plus c'est chris tu veux te
soutiens cookies c'est pas mal mais ça
ça peut pas gagner ce à quoi ça peut pas
gagner ça peut bien gagner faute doit
être plus rôle pour gagner amoureux
taqwa moi j'ai vous souvenez du de
maurice tounes qui chantait sur les
chantiers il parlait et l'ambiance et
les passants et les voisins sur son
balcon depuis son balcon est là pour
fêter la fin du déconfinement bas pour
remercier tout le monde il a décidé
d'inviter juste petite question ça va
vous je rigole de débat mais dès 16h30
chose en rigole supporter plus de 50
jours c'est ce que j'ai vu en 1h10 à vos
invités
[Musique]
[Rires]
il s'appelle lyonnais sur nes 6,6 et
pour remercier son regard si l'appel
milieu de semaine prochaine mercredi
considéré que c'était parfait tel
déconfinement décidé d'inviter un groupe
de joueuses de chanteurs marocains
je me régale en soit la touche du bois
il souffle pendant ce court seulement et
on va les supporter j'ai une surprise
pour vous tous et ce à la surprise année
là
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
j'adore et bravo l'unesco son passeport
qui est exceptionnel bull s est pas
obligé trois semaines mais aussi parce
que voilà c'était avant j'étais le duo
et bravo raymond tu sais pas si tu vas
gagner avec ça mais j'aime bien j'aime
bien aller
la vidéo de valérie bénaïm du jour alors
donnez vous c'est vous nous rejoignez on
est en direct quand j'ai commencé que du
kif
on ne fait que rigoler on veut vous
sortir douala de la morosité ambiante
et quoi de mieux qu'une aire mais quoi
de mieux qu'une herbe folle pour sur son
sidérant liberté dans la nature pour se
sentir bien moi voilà moi regarder voilà
ça fait du bien regarder ces magnifiques
voilà c'est du bambou à gaza tom sawyer
l'amérique le symbole de la liberté
allez-y benhaim alors vous savez que
d'habitude quand on parle de la banlieue
c'est pas forcément pas perdre et qui
limite qui columbo dans le pays
si bête ngai merci oui alors donc se
parler de la banlieue et vous savez très
souvent quand on parle de la banlieue
c'est pas pour les bonnes initiatives
c'est pas pour les trucs qui fonctionne
et son sympathique voit là et bien là
justement l'initiative à vous proposer
c'est un des jeunes qui ont fait l 2
shon oui des jeunes des genres y va
j'envisage qui ont fêté le déconfinement
en dansant en chantant un truc qui est
très feelgood est très agréable à
regarder
c'est broadway en banlieue et je trouve
ça très sympa c'est fort voilà jouent
alors j'ai rien compris mais j'ai envie
de voir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous associons à respecter les distances
de sécurité
je rappelle un très égale danger de très
galles security c'est comme en voiture
maintenant attention de ne pas toucher
le pare choc arrière même si je sais
benhaim ça fait longtemps qu'on vous l'a
pas touché les séries où ils se
serraient c'est très sympathique mais
c'est tout ce que le gouvernement
rouzier sa banque et des bandes vont de
joie comme ça que les gens fassent la
vérité vous dirais le gouvernement je
serai comme ça oui merci
alors vous aussi monsieur blessure toc
toc sur tik tok sur sa marque et je me
suis baladé à l'aller sur tik tok
il a rendu je me suis balayé sur toi
comme doc tout à l'heure m e jean marc
morandini et leader wydad ac dumas jean
marc elle est toujours leader
d'ailleurs ce soir c'est le retour de
crime sedwill et après nous et le
tutorat la famille besnier ce sera
direct après un passage une question
chef
oui est ce que cette semaine en a le
droit a enfin des inédits dans les
émissions sur les chaînes je suis encore
des ruines alors ça y est l'heure tout
est assez léger bien que là les
personnes continuent oui mais alors mais
s'est méthodiquement reprend et ben on
est ravi mais pas avec moi si tu avais
beau c'est un peu tout sort et se
construit non c'est vrai ouais ouais
regardez elle tue pas rappelant comme ça
on dirait vraiment une fleuriste va le
chercher des sons qui fait balader sur
techtoc et je suis tombé sur une femme
la soixantaine un peu excentrique qui a
acheté une coloration pour cheveux
elle a essayé elle a crié c'est vrai
mais vous le regardez
mais ça donnerait juste géraldine il
faut que tu que tu pack non faut que tu
es ce que tu partes en bloc numéro 3
monsieur bouchard dont l'un qui est en
train de faire un truc merci hier après
midi chez d'acheter des produits pour
faire des mèches je demande à nos
conseillères dans une grande surface
qu'on lui regardez moi ça mes cheveux
sont tous richard
mammare c'est que moi l'ont dit mais je
vais avoir ma ronde face à face ou de
mes collègues regardez-moi ça regardez
moi ça c'est sympa franchement des
enfants la soeur de rené qu est ce qu a
été la soeur de rooney c'est quoi
c'est la soeur de rené et qu'est-ce qui
va comment elle va aller c'est pas
possible on va la ramener gentiment à et
qui région michel oui voila moi plus
l'instant ma vidéo préférée c'est celle
de maxime arrêt mais attention la dark a
été sympa moi je suis tombé sur un homme
qui avait que des confinement et besoin
de faire prendre l'air à son corps et à
toutes les parties de son corps
ça m'a fait rire évidemment merci c'est
un très beau lancement en janvier c'est
ce soir vous êtes habillé tout seul vous
habiller beaucoup mieux sol qu avec des
stylistes et réfléchie 10 pour l'année
prochaine
sinon quelques mois après ce repérage
pour le confinement saura prendre
l'apéro les gares bondées confirme en
tout cas mon déconfinement lui la
liberté de la france cette fois j'ai une
vidéo hors concours je vous le dis à mon
avis pour moi je viens vérité elle bat
toutes vos vidéos
c'est une mamie qui fait un bilan des
deux mois de confinement et elle démonte
tout les gens qui se sont mis en avant
sur les réseaux sociaux
regardez je pense que voilà c'est
quelqu'un qui fait partie de l'un de
leurs ma famille profite sincèrement les
gens qui font des lives 15 fois par jour
mais personne leur vie qu'on s'en va
vraiment les coudes on a rien à [ __ ]
et je vous épargne ce qui se sont
découvert un talent ahmad chef cuisinier
mais voulez je vous dise dos plat ils
ont l'air dégueulasse qui pue la merde
pour moi c'est de l'or
il résulte à regarder cette vidéo vous
avez préféré merci nous dînons régie
merci nous nous raymond a macéré moquer
la meilleure vidéo et 44 avant je suis
pas mère vidéo le monarque à séville 0 %
à mal
[Rires]